the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
your host for tonight's show please
welcome Amy Mark's cores and Debbie
Monterey
[Music]
everyone looks so beautiful good evening
I'm Amy Mark scores from KMOX and you
may recognize my voice as a co-host on
the show alongside Chris ranji on behalf
of the St Louis chess club and World
Chess Hall of Fame welcome to the sixth
annual strategy across the board Gala
and thank you yes Applause for Amy she's
fantastic
[Laughter]
Debbie Monterey you may also recognize
my voice as well as the host of total
information am on KMOX and we would just
like to thank all of you for being here
tonight to all of you here in the room
and all of you at home across the world
we're so happy to be with you here
tonight in fact apparently the chess
club and the World Chess Hall of Fame
liked us enough doing this last year
that they invited us back again so we're
really pleased to be here with all of
you tonight and Amy has really been
working on her chess game over the last
year I've been working really hard I
made a lot of improvements which is not
saying much but yes if you want to feel
better about your chess game please play
me before we get started this evening
though we would like to definitely
recognize our presenting sponsors
first and foremost Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield and Rex sinkfield co-founders
of the St Louis chess club
thank you
thank you for your contributions and
visions of Chess in St Louis and around
the world let's give them a round of
applause for what they have done for
chess in St Louis
and perhaps perhaps we can stand to
recognize them as well also Edward Jones
has been a loyal supporter of the St
Louis chess club since 2015. we really
appreciate Edward Jones support and by
the way congratulations on Edward Jones
being the corporate Chesley Champions
once again for the 2022 fall league we
would like to recognize three other
qualifying teams many of which are here
with us tonight including worldwide
technology Enterprise and Doherty
Business Solutions
would all of the members of the
corporate chess League please stand up
all right I see some people standing
congratulations and thank you
and again thank you to Edward Jones for
all that you do and congratulations once
again
next we would like to thank
our presenting sponsor Ascension who has
been a stakeholder in creating their own
program that has been in existence a
program that has been implemented in
multiple schools in the Ferguson
Florissant School District under the
your move chess program it's a
partnership between Ascension and the
chess club for the past eight years
a special thanks especially to the
Executive Vice President and chief
marketing officer and Communications
Officer Nick ragone for making chess a
success in the Ferguson Florissant
School District serving more than 4
000 students to date we truly appreciate
your support and Nick where are you
there's Nick congratulations and thank
you
SSM Health Cardinal Glennon Children's
Hospital thanks to your support and
enthusiasm about Chess Cardinal Glennon
and the St Louis chess campus have
developed a partnership bringing chess
to patients at Cardinal Glennon this
partnership serves as a mentorship for
kids wanting to learn how to play chess
the St Louis chess campus aims to serve
as many peaceful as possible and this is
one more Avenue to reaching children and
a very special thank you to Stephen
burghart president of Cardinal Glennon
for chairing our event tonight Stephen
would you please stand
there he is
thank you to all of our generous donors
here tonight your support is greatly
appreciated so before we begin dinner
just a reminder that the silent auction
will close at 8 pm there will not be a
formal announcement so please keep an
eye on your mobile phones and get your
bids in we do have a great program
planned for you tonight so enjoy your
dinner and we will be back shortly thank
you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
once again please welcome to the stage
Amy marks cores and Debbie Monterey
welcome back to strategy across the
board before I bring our Gala chair to
the stage we would like to recognize
some very important guests that are with
us here tonight first and foremost Dr
Jeannie Karen sinkfield and rexingfield
again thank you so much for your support
here tonight not just for chess but for
the city of St Louis and Beyond
we do have you're all All-Stars you're
all super wonderful and we're so glad
you're with us here tonight but we
really have some folks that we want to
point out to you who are with us here
including Lieutenant Governor Mike Kehoe
and Claudia Kehoe with us this evening
lieutenant governor and Mrs Kehoe thank
you so much for being with us here
tonight
and thank you for your support
also with us tonight
this gentleman needs no introduction
he is a 13-time gold glove Award winner
a 15-time All-Star and arguably the best
defensive shortstop ever
would you please welcome St Louis
Cardinals shortstop in Major League
Baseball Hall of Famer Ozzie Smith with
us tonight
and since we're on the baseball theme
John Costello John is a former relief
pitcher in Major League Baseball who
played with the St Louis Cardinals from
1988 to 1990 also with the Montreal
Expos and San Diego Padres John
thank you for being with us tonight
and we have a few grand Masters in the
room with us tonight of course so when I
announce your name would you please
stand
we have a goat in the room with us
tonight
the good kind of goat of course Grand
Master Judith Polgar greatest of all
time female chess player and universally
recognized as the strongest female chess
player of all time
great to see you here
Grand Master Fabiano caruana as St Louis
resident 2018 World Championship
Contender and two-time U.S chess
champion as well as this year's American
Cup and chess 9 LX Champion Fabiano
Carolina
Grand Master Lenny or Dominguez a
five-time Cuban chess champion who moved
from Cuba to St Louis in 2018 to play
for the United States
since changing federations to the U.S he
has been a regular contender in the U.S
chess championships and the grand chess
tour
Grandmaster VAR akobian I'm not sure
where VAR is there's VAR
also at St Louis resident and one of the
best American chess players he's
represented the United States in several
olympiads and United States
championships
Grand Master livon aronian
he recently changed federations from
Armenia to the United States and has
also made Saint Louis his home
Grand Master Christian sharilia
Mizzou chess coach and St Louis chess
club commentator
Grand Master Alejandro Ramirez
slew chess coach and St Louis chess club
commentator
Ray Robson St Louis local Webster Alum
and Elite Grand Master with a rating
over 2700 where where's
Ray
well that's applaud for him even though
we can't quite see him
Grand Master Alex you're malinski
two-time U.S champion and U.S Chess Hall
of Fame inductee
tatev abrahamian Armenian woman Grand
Master who's represented the United
States in several olympiads and U.S
women's championships
we also have members of the St Louis
University Collegiate chess team with us
would you stand so we know where you are
tonight
there we go
thank you for being here
we also have a number of Educators with
us tonight all of whom have chess
programs in their schools Educators
please stand up so we can recognize you
all right
thank you
I'd also like to recognize all of our
board members from the St Louis chess
club and the world chess club Hall of
Fame what our board members please stand
board members thank you
also all of the people who made it
possible for us to be here tonight the
event committee members who gave so
generously of their time and efforts to
make the sixth annual strategy across
the board possible event committee
members please stand so we can thank you
for this beautiful room and this
beautiful evening
truly we truly are in the presence
we truly are in the presence of
greatness tonight and now I'd like to
introduce you to someone who has been
instrumental in making this event such a
success president of SSM Health Cardinal
Glennon Children's Hospital Stephen
burgart
Stephen Burkhart serves as the president
of SSM Health Cardinal Glennon
Children's Hospital Cardinal Glennon
Children's Hospital ranks among the
nation's top children's hospitals in U.S
news and World Report Burkhart graduated
from Baylor University and earned his
master's degree in healthcare
administration from Trinity University
Burkhart is a three-time winner of
Becker's 40 under Florida 40 Hospital
executive rising stars and he is
involved with Community organizations
and Boards including ukulele kids club
Unity foundation and Children's Hospital
Association education and Communications
so please a round of applause for
Stephen burghart
[Applause]
thank you
um it is a real pleasure to be here and
I also want to thank
um I have a whole table of friends
family and our team at Cardinal Glennon
over here at table eight and I really
want to recognize uh the team of Health
caregivers because if you didn't know
there's a pandemic on and it's really
impacted what we do for a living and to
say that the team has not only
persevered but is truly offering the
most exceptional care to our community
right now they've just done beautiful
exceptional work so I just want to thank
them if you all would stand up if you
work at Glennon Glennon folks
come on Becky
Hannah Kim
all right and most importantly tonight
is a very special night
it's my anniversary
so they weren't even going to give me a
speaking part uh but I said it's my
anniversary you got to let me come up
and show a picture of my gorgeous wife
Michelle if she would stand
please
I'm not leaving the stage until you
stand up you know please all right thank
you
um so uh she met me back when I was um
selling collection agency services and
uh she stuck with me now for more than
20 years 17 in marriage and I'm just so
grateful to her everything that I've
ever done has been through through her
and she is just a powerful person and
I'm grateful for her so thank you
now the one thing I'll say real quick
about Cardinal Glennon is um so we serve
about 200 000 kids a year at Cardinal
Glennon if you can imagine there's about
600 000 kids in our region and that
region is from Springfield Missouri to
Springfield Illinois
and uh we take care of every child
regardless of anything in the world uh
we we don't care if they can pay for
care where they're from or what they've
got going on we can absolutely take care
of them and as was mentioned earlier our
one of our passions is to make sure that
they get to the joy of new experiences
so while you're in the hospital for
Cystic Fibrosis or cancer or even just
the common cold that maybe if you're a
young child we want to make sure you
have access as many experiences as
humanly possible and chess is a very
powerful experience for our kids to have
and so the chess club graciously has
worked with our team and child life to
create access to learning chess while
these children are hospitalized so that
their memories can be about learning
chess or learning music learning arts
instead of learning about their cancer
diagnosis or their Cardiology issues so
I just want to thank the entire chess
club the Chess Hall of Fame especially
the singfield family who really have
brought chess to St Louis in such a
powerful way and thank you all for being
here and supporting uh this effort and I
pray that you will raise your paddles
strongly later thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
and thank you Stephen
all right it's time for us to talk a
little bit more about the man who made a
lot of this possible because the chess
club and the world chess club Hall of
Fame would not exist in St Louis if it
were not for the co-founders Dr Jeannie
and Rex sinkfield
rexingfield was born and raised in St
Louis
after an early and Unexpected death of
his father a young Rex and his brother
Jerry moved to the Saint Vincent home
for children
at St Vincent's
Rex was reared by the sisters of
Christian charity he studied hard
performed daily chores and he found ways
to make his peers laugh and he
persevered
upon High School graduation from deberg
Rex entered the Seminary
after three years at Seminary Rex made
the difficult decision to not further
pursue the priesthood and he enrolled at
St Louis University
there he majored in philosophy and
business with his undergraduate degrees
in hand Rex packed his bags and he moved
to Chicago to study under Nobel Prize
winners Eugene FEMA and Merton Miller at
the University of Chicago and he earned
his masters of business administration
Rex went on to work for the American
National Bank of Chicago where he helped
invent a type of passive investing and
pioneered the first index funds which
formed part of the inspiration for his
future endeavors
together with David Booth with whom he
studied at the University of Chicago Rex
co-founded the investment firm
dimensional fund advisors in 1981.
dimensional fund advisors applies
academic research to the Practical world
of investing and today the firm has more
than a trillion dollars in global assets
and was recently named retirement leader
of the year
index investing by the way has become
the most popular form of investing
worldwide
as a leader within the St Louis region
and across the state of Missouri Rex
actively participates in Civic and
cultural institutions Beyond his and his
wife Jeannie's generous Financial
contributions Rex serves on the boards
of the Missouri Botanical Garden
Missouri History Museum Opera theater of
St Louis St Louis Art Museum St Louis
Symphony Contemporary Art Museum and of
course St Louis University his most
recent accomplishment both he and his
wife Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
co-founder were inducted into the U.S
Chess Hall of Fame for their generous
contributions in chess so
congratulations to Rex and Genie ladies
and gentlemen will you please welcome to
this stage the incredible and one of a
kind Mr Rex sinkfield
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much Debbie that was that
was very kind Northern and I expected
but you read it exactly the way I wrote
it
um
so thank all of you for your support and
for attending this evening each year I'm
impressed with the Gale and I'm always
pleasantly surprised by what the
committee and staff
creates and produces it's absolutely
beautiful in here tonight and it's all
because of their work
and I had no idea what the chess club
would be when we started it as my wife
likes to say a chess club how expensive
canopy
so
so let's recognize a given Applause to
the people that really do the work and
make everything happen and that's
general manager of the chess club and
Hall of Fame Joy Bray
[Applause]
and Tony Rich the executive director of
the chess club
and Shannon Bailey and Emily Allred
chief curators of the Hall of Fame
and a quick thank you to Lauren Stewart
and her team in developing our donor
bases and planning for such a wonderful
evening
these organizations their hard work
their creativity brings programming into
the classroom throughout St Louis and
around the world
as you've all seen some graphics in the
slide this evening I would like to point
out that it's been 50 years since Bobby
Fischer defeated Boris spaski the World
Chess Hall of Fame currently has an
exhibition celebrating that match that
all of you should visit and experience
I can't believe actually it's been 50
years
since Fisher's Victory it seems like it
was yesterday those of you who are old
enough to remember yesterday
you remember that this chess match as
Dick Cavett said was the most watched
a competitive event in the history of
the world
it was watched everywhere in every
country followed by every newspaper
usually on the front page of every paper
showing the moves of those games of that
day it was truly incredible
and sadly we're never going to have
another one like that but we may have
some good ones
and I'm also very proud and excited that
we have with us Grand Master Judith
progar the highest ranked woman ever in
chess
and she's here for her induction into
the World Chess Hall of Fame something
richly deserved and overdue
and Judith although it's your first
visit to St Louis I've talked with the
mayor's office and you're invited to
stay
well thank you again everybody for
joining us we appreciate your support
and contributions to these organizations
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you so much Rex and now I would
like to bring to the stage the President
of the U.S chess trust Beatrice
Marinello the U.S chess trust Works to
promote and support chess throughout the
United States please welcome to the
stage and to St Louis Beatrice Marinello
foreign
[Music]
honor to be here tonight
um it is my pleasure to introduce Sunil
verimantry he's a chess educator and
legendary chess coach and the liaison
from the trust to the Hall of Fame so
Sunil could you please come to the stage
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Beatrice
ladies and gentlemen
distinguished guests
I first met Judith poga as a 10 year old
when she played in a tournament that I
organized at Hunter College campus
school in Manhattan
of course she won the tournament with a
perfect score
it was already evident back then
that she had a presence about her
an undeniable confidence in her
abilities as a player
Judith is a chess Prodigy in the true
sense of the word
and not surprising perhaps when you
consider that as the youngest of three
chess playing sisters
she had the benefit of absorbing all
that just knowledge around her
but what is unique in Judith's
illustrious stress career
is that she
competed consistently
almost exclusively
against
members of the opposite sex
in fact when Judith played in the 1990
World youth championships in Fond du Lac
Wisconsin
the only time that event has ever been
held in the United States
Judith played in the 14 and under open
section
and won the title easily
Judith went on
to achieve the men's Grandmaster title
at the age of 15 years and five months a
full month ahead of the legendary Bobby
Fisher
Judith has won the Hungarian national
championships and proudly represented a
country in many prestigious events
notably in olympiads
and in one world championship cycle
it's true that Judith and her sisters
played on a women's team in the women's
Olympiad in 1988 and 1990
and won first place but that was at a
time when fide did not really allow
women to compete in the same section as
men as soon as that became possible
Judith qualified and represented the
men's team
at the at the olympiads
but I'm not here to
provide a laundry list of Judy's
achievements we all know what a great
player she is you can also you can read
all about it when you visit the Hall of
Fame
suffice to say that Judas is very simply
considered to be the greatest woman
player of all time
there's no question about that
so only woman to have challenged the
dominance of men
and broken into the top ten in the world
achieving a peak ranking of number eight
in the world
instead I'd like to talk about
two
important points in Judith's uh chess
career
or post stress career
in March 2017
she was recognized as a planet 50 50
champion
a spokesperson for United Nations
initiative
that sought to establish gender equality
by the year 2030
during her remarks at the ceremony in
the United Nations building
Judith echoed the feelings of her father
Dr Laszlo Polgar in stating
that women could achieve the same as men
given the proper opportunities
the second point I want to mention
is Judith's creation of the Judith Pogo
chess Foundation
and the launching of the global chess
challenge which is held every October in
Budapest
this event has grown into one of the
most prestigious events in the world
Judith showed that she not only had the
support of government but that she could
include the private sector as well to
make a wonderful event
and so with the authority vested in me
I hereby
if I find the gavel
induct Grandmaster Judith poga into the
World Chess Hall of Fame
and
intuitive Rex Genie and Beatrice would
you please come on stage
Rex and Genie also please
and beer trees also please
[Applause]
video
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign thank you very much it's very
touching to be here
I just like to say a few words as it is
a very special moment
I believe that to become Champion you
need to have Grit
to be a person with passion and
perseverance of course you need a lot of
other things but I think these two or
without these two we cannot achieve big
results
when I was a little girl
five years old later teenager a woman a
mother later
I had huge challenges and but I liked
them
because I was the character of a
competitor
and here is the moment where I want to
say a few thank yous first of all to my
family to my father who believed that
it's possible to have a very different
life from other kids and he was thinking
that homeschooling and focusing on one
specific field gives you success and
happiness
he gave a very special love to the game
of chess
and also it was always very important
for him that I become also very creative
which I benefited in other films than
chess
of course I want to say thanks to my mom
she's a very special lady who gave up
everything at the same time she got many
things by being next to me and being my
next to my sisters and up to the day she
gives great example of lifelong learning
and many other things
but of course I have to say thank you
for my sister Susan she was a great
inspiration as she's seven years older
so by the time I started to play chess
she was already a pretty good player
and of course Sophia who is my best
friend she's always cheerful happy and
the real artist of the family
but of course I have to thank to the
organizers who invited me all along from
young age teenager as a prodigy later on
as a good Grandmaster to give the
opportunity for me to perform and to
achieve what I did but of course without
the opponent it would be impossible to
achieve those results and to create
those beautiful games
and of course I like to say that in this
room we have great fantastic photo
players including my friends and
ex-competitors of mine
of course I want to say thank you to my
daughter Hannah and Oliver who is their
home and they ever already
in school when I was still in
competition so
they were tolerant and they were also
supportive but most of all I want to
thank to my husband who is supporting
and my biggest supporter of all and he's
standing by me for more than 20 years
whatever ideas I have by eight years of
the chessboard
and finally I would like to express my
gratitude being here in Saint Louis
because this city made history by
creating a chess club and be having the
Hall of Fame
and it's having an amazing chess history
showing for example now the Fisher
exhibition but continuously contributes
to chess which is maybe I can say
without exaggeration the most important
building in chess right now thank you
very much
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
to be here and I'm also honored to
introduce Sharon Carpenter Sharon
Carpenter was born in the UK currently
lives in LA and is an award-winning
broadcast journalist TV presenter and
producer whom you may have seen covering
the Oscars for BBC America speaking on
the Royals on CNN or hosting the viral
quiz show HQ trivia she has interviewed
countless a-listers from Oprah to Meryl
Streep to Rihanna
but this may be her biggest one yet so
please welcome Sharon now as she sits
down with Judith Polgar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why did I wear these heels
Judith I am so excited to chat with you
tonight you are a huge inspiration
massive congratulations so once again a
round of applause for Judah kogar
Judith talk to us about what tonight's
honor means to you being inducted into
the wild Chess Hall of Fame and during
your first visit to the St Louis chess
campus it's a big deal for you
well of course it's a it's a very
special moment and they that I did get
inducted here in Saint Louis to the
world had chest of Hall of Fame and
because it's a it's a not only
acknowledgment but also in such a
special location
absolutely and you and I were chatting
yesterday you were talking about how you
are the most current inductee into the
World Chess Hall of Fame Bobby Fischer
was the first inductee into the wild
Chess Hall of Fame and and that's very
meaningful to you tell us why
yes when I saw this that Bobby was the
first one and I'm Number 40th in the
Hall of Fame uh it was special because
one of my biggest results was when I was
15 and I broke Bobby Fisher's record and
just a few years later he was playing
the rematch against Maurice besky and
shortly after that he moved to Hungary
because my father invited him and he was
spending quite a few years in Hungary
and we had some meetings with him also
yeah you got to meet him did you guys
chat about you breaking his record
well because you're the main topic we
were discussing you stayed or you
avoided that word he liked humor a lot
Bobby but this was not part of that got
it got it makes sense makes sense now
the World Chess Hall of Fame is all
about celebrating the history of Chess
as well as highlighting the impact it's
had on arts and culture as well talk to
us about how important it is to know
chess outside of just playing the game
these aspects of Chess as well and which
of these areas are most inspiring to you
Judith
well to tell you the truth when I was a
kid and for several decades I was very
much focusing on chess as a sport but
later on I also of course I realized how
rich chess is and the the world Hall of
Fame the exhibitions they have and of
course I've heard a lot of them before
visiting it yesterday
I think it's very important that the
game which is 1500 years old that it's
not only recognized as a sport but also
how much it affects the culture it it is
in many different ways part of not only
history of every country but generally
chess connects Us in so many different
ways and this Museum this building shows
the diversity how chess connects
generally the society between anybody
different age groups whatever you can
find something that even if you don't
play Chess at all you will find it
amazing something you can connect with
and you saw the recent Exhibition at the
World Chess Hall of Fame Bobby Fisher
yeah the exhibition here it's amazing I
even found myself there with the picture
but taking selfies I saw some of your
selfies the exhibition is amazing it
covers
many amazing things like handwriting
things
pictures and videos and audio so if
somebody did not know him which I barely
can imagine that someone didn't hear of
him but they can get to know him pretty
well through this exhibition and
speaking of amazing I would love to know
where did you get your drive your
passion for playing chess for competing
winning and just shattering records time
and time again extraordinary
I believe I got it in the beginning from
my parents they were extremely
determined about our education and then
I was somehow very fast in developing
and
somehow good scores win game after game
it does give you a good drive
that keeps you going that feeling of
euphoria absolutely I was nine years old
when my first International success was
in the New York open unrated section and
and that was a real uh speeding up my
development
now in terms of your chest style you're
somebody who uh for to a great extent
you love taking risks didn't you that'd
be sort of the sure bet but no you're
gonna go for the the riskier move to
make the game more interesting
well yeah I had the quite a rough image
probably some people
like LaVon and some others may may tell
their experience that it was sweating
when I was attacking them I had a bad
image being very aggressive but don't
think I'm throwing plates at home no I'm
only aggressive on the chessboard and
which means that I was always ready or
for a long time I was attacking the king
I wanted to make my strategy very much
straightforward
and
that's how it was so when you see that
bead of sweats from your opponent you
know you're in a good place
well I don't remember anymore I retired
in 2014. that's not that long ago
well I have a different face when I was
playing trust me I see it you know
you're not the only one who is asking
that especially when a friend of mine I
was in in the end and we're on holiday
and I went to an orphanage house to play
chess there and then my friend would say
oh my God I never saw you like this okay
we have we need to see
when you start looking chess and you
were doing it for 35 years or 38 years
you simply have a completely different
flow even if I play against someone who
is much lower rated or weaker somehow I
do have a different look and face
expression okay okay so you grow up in a
in a chess household you mentioned your
two sisters Sophia and Susan who
excelled at the game as well can you
tell us what it was like having chess
ingrained in your soul from an early age
and and your father kind of looked at
this as a bit of an educational
experiment didn't he
yes he did say this when we were kids I
would prefer saying it that he created a
very special lifestyle to us the main
idea was that we were homeschooled and
we were focusing on chess every day with
training in the beginning of course it
was little
after all it's a game so it's not very
painful to play a game but of course
later on it became more time that I was
engaged and then it was in the beginning
it was a game later on it became a sport
but at the same time it was also a huge
art because my style is very artistic I
always liked the
exceptional Solutions unexpected
Solutions but it was also science in
some way because I had to make a lot of
research to be able to to play better
and better and the environment I grew up
it was special from the sense that
everything was about Chess my parents
were always talking about Chess planning
new tournaments new coaches and in this
environment it was very natural that uh
it was good that way and a little birdie
told me sort of be careful what you
asked for your dad wanted a chest star
and then you beat him blindfolded at
seven years old
well yeah it was I was seven when I beat
my father already and I think he was he
was just happy for that because he knew
that by growing and winning against him
who wasn't who is an amateur player up
to today he was happy that I was
progressing but after that definitely I
had to have other trainers
when was that point when you realized
okay I have the ability to be the best
and I'm gonna make this happen
um
did that cross your mind
that was the key year for me in 1988
that was really a year where experts
could not follow how fast I was like
growing in my rating points and the
success I had so that was the moment
when it was it was really nice to win
like seven tournaments I won and also it
was part of it the the women's Olympia
together with my sisters so that was
something very special at the same time
when you're in it from day to day you
don't feel it exactly the way
people look at it from outside so some
decade later when I had bad form for
example I was looking wow I made 12
victories and one drawing that little
Olympian wow I'm jealous of myself
so it's looking back on it reflecting
back when you realize yeah then I think
it is with every sport person that we
are so busy and engaged in the daily
training and the competition that the
competition is over the next day you go
back and continue trading that it has to
be sometime passing when you really say
wow that was really good wow awesome so
so let's talk about the Queen's Gambit
which a lot of people thought that show
was about you you actually got calls
from people congratulating you didn't
you yeah that was funny that obviously I
got the tons of interview requests but
also some friends of mine said wow I
didn't know there was a series but well
not quite but at the end of it it
resembles my story that I did win
against the best competitors absolutely
and we're going to talk about that uh
but talk to me about what you saw in
terms of this phenomenon from the show
and bringing so much mainstream
attention to chess it wasn't just here
in the US was it it was also in Hungary
all over Europe absolutely it was a
worldwide storm of Chess heat and fever
uh I think there was nothing like that
before but I thought that maybe 50 years
ago when Bobby Fischer won his crown it
was could be something similar to that
but this series had nothing to do with
politics it was just a character movie
showing chess in a in a very interesting
fun way and what is more important in a
very realistic and authentic way and
well I was the one of some of the first
people who I saw it because when it came
out I just watched it
stay home it has been binge watched the
the entire season absolutely but in
those days it was not difficult because
I think all of us were locked up true
true a little fun fact as well you I
know you noticed watching Beth Harmon
the main character you saw some
Tendencies and some body language and
gestures that looked kind of familiar
didn't you
yeah actually I sew some I have also
some picture which is very similar and
also some people were telling me that
well there are some similarities which
is kind of could be understandable
because of course to play it well she
you're studying the best to
how it is the best but she's amazing I
talked to her in a in a small talk we
had a chat it was amazing how she played
chess and how authentic she did it while
she doesn't play Chess at all so it was
a choreography for her I mean
sometimes I have problems remembering
moves so yeah
that was kind of interesting amazing and
the fictional character Beth Harmon
faced a a slew of challenges of course
as a chess Prodigy and then as a woman
uh dominating in a male dominated world
how much can you relate to that
fictional story and then tell us about
some of your own experiences and some of
the challenges you had to go through in
real life on your way to the top
I think actually in the movie it was not
uh specifically focusing on the the
ladies expect it was but in reality I
think in many occasions it's more
difficult to girls to excel between the
men or in open section this is what I
felt though I didn't have so many
difficulties disregard I had my parents
who were supporting me very much which
was very important that they were not
limiting me they were always supporting
me in getting better and better at chess
also my sisters and my coaches so this
was something something very important
for me when I was a kid of course
my opponents adult opponents usually
they were never healthy they always had
excuses headache Bellic or whatever
suddenly call out sick the day of yeah
that that was quite normal but later on
when I became a teenager age 15 16 they
were still skeptical that okay she's a
prodigy but what happens after several
years she's not going to be that good
anymore and and then much later already
one of the nicest compliments I received
it was when and then the world champions
had when a journalist was asking well
what do you think about Judith as a
woman play and she just had enough of
these questions as well she's one of us
and well I I felt my way to get the
respect from my opponents and
competitors God and when you said that
you heard all these excuses you mean
after you would beat somebody you'd beat
a gentleman and then oh well I wasn't
feeling well anyway that kind of thing
[Laughter]
got it how much harder do you think you
had to to work to prove yourself
I believe I had to prove myself like
five to ten times more as if I would
have been a talented boy at the same
time I can say that later on once I got
into the top 10 or even to the top 50
already I got invitations and maybe I
had a little Advantage because I was the
only woman who was good enough for that
level
and but for me it was okay because I I
like those challenges and it was it was
my mindset that I was ready for that
fun fact by the way you have beaten is
it 11 World Champs either raining or
former World Champs including Magnus
Carlsen which was a fun game to watch
Blitz game which is on YouTube check it
out uh how does that make you feel
actually that was not the only game I've
won against him oh
wait how
do tell Judith do tell
the the reason I'm telling you because
it was interesting that once I won
against him in Mexico in a rapid game
that I had a very bad position but
somehow I tricked him which was like a
shock for him and it was the face that
you brought out right
that made him sweat and then the the one
you're recalling now which you've seen
it must have been in the after the
during the candidates tournament when I
visited Madrid and he came to Madrid for
the last few rounds and then we ended up
for some filming in the retiro park in
Madrid and they just wanted to make some
shots as we played the game we were just
chatting we were on some b-roll that
kind of thing and then I noticed the
winning move I was just so shocked
myself and when I played it he was even
more shocked
so that was great fun and it was even
more fun that on Times Square on the
Billboards we had it for like before the
chess festival for 10 days looping this
position they were advertising it
weren't they yeah Times Square well
actually the global chess Festival was
advertised but uh that you were up there
and you'll win and this game was there
so I was happy to see them amazing well
this is a question that gets pondered
Upon A Lot what can we do to get more
girls and women into professional chess
and playing at the levels that you were
able to play at
do you do you have an answer for that
one well maybe this is the question I'm
asked most frequently and it's the most
difficult question to answer because
it's uh it's not a one minute reply
if I have to reply very quickly and fast
I would say it's education
it's education
it's educating parents it's educating
the society it's educating the coaches
because it's not the same how you
encourage a girl right now if most of
the cases what happens if you see a 70
year old girl or a boy being talented
then the girl will be encouraged to
become women's world champion for a boy
they would say well you can get Magnus
Carlson in reality there is such a big
difference in rating points it's like if
you're saying someone
on academic level that for girls you can
become having a PhD doctor degree to the
boy you're saying that you're going to
be a Nobel Prize winner
so I think the most important thing is
not to limit girls have the same
expectations and moreover not to compare
boys to girls just get the best you can
and then I think slowly it can demolish
great advice because one of your things
was you actually you didn't like to play
too often in the women's specific
tournaments right that wasn't your goal
your goal was to play in the tournaments
for everyone that just happened to be
dominated by men
absolutely it was uh my parents who were
very supportive on this that basically
chess is not a physical sport it's a
mental sport so if you get the same
circumstances and opportunities as other
boys then you should be get the maximum
of your level and the basically this is
why I could become so much on the top of
Chess because there was no limitations
wow well you mentioned uh education so
when I think chess and education I think
kids being taught how to play the game
but it's so much broader than that and
this is something you have focused on
with your foundation for the past 10
years the St Louis chess club as well
focuses on the benefits of Chess when it
comes to education so talk to us about
how broad broadly chess can be used to
teach kids and what kind of skills are
kids learning from this
actually I'm very happy that
nowadays I see everywhere that there are
great programs running everywhere in the
world of course some are better some are
not so good but there are many different
ways how you can have chess in the
classroom or even in kindergartens I
mean preschoolers also you can use chess
and I believe that the chess is a
magical game for this century and for
the upcoming this next Generation
because with just you can develop kids
skills what they need in other fields as
well and after all it's a game right so
during the game if you just look at the
board they learn how to make strategies
right they make decisions without
noticing it and realizing it you have to
take responsibility there is an
immediate feedback whether you made a
good decision or a bad decision you have
to reconsider after every move so you
always have to be extremely flexible or
resilient to be be able to get better
and change your strategy I think this is
one of the key elements in success of
Modern Age how resilient you are and how
flexible you are to realize the new
opportunities and realize what are the
bad things you had and the chess can be
integrated into classrooms and different
subjects like math and and other things
it develops also emotional intelligence
so there are a lot of skills which kids
can develop without realizing by playing
chess that they are going to get better
and they can be better in other subjects
as well they perform better academically
and also I have many friends from all
kinds of workplace from doctors to
musicians to business people who always
tell me the feedback also that how much
useful it is for them when they do their
decisions and and I think it's already
proven and it's fantastic that here in
St Louis there is a huge hundreds of
thousands of kids are involved in the
program
thanks to Rex and and Jane rexville
thank you because this is something I
think it's amazing for kids and and it
works so I think teachers also
themselves they realize it
how much beneficial it is for kids in my
Foundation we had we have 10 years
anniversary this year we have about 60
000 rats thank you sixty thousand kids
annually we have an educational course
for teachers which was completed nearly
4 000 teachers wow and so we also
experienced it that the teachers
themselves who use chess as a skill
building
tool that they simply have something
that they can fit in all the other
elements and knowledge into the chess
board or related to chess so chess is
something that I think it will be
similar to math that's simply in the
future within 10 years let's say let's
put that goal every Institute will have
well I learned from you when we were
chatting uh this I thought was
fascinating it can also be used for
physical to teach physical education PE
we call it back in Europe or gym I
thought that was interesting yeah I have
the Julius bulgar method and we have
three parts it's for kindergarten
preschool Elementary School and also the
third leg we have the chessby where you
have to realize that you have a chest
rug pretty big one and then the kids are
going and having different movements on
the chessboard so the chessboard can be
in a rock form or the chessboard itself
it can be extremely motivational for
kids yeah it looks like a lot of fun for
sure now I know you also upon retirement
you you told me that you found a lot of
your chess skills with transferable
skills to Everyday Life
oh well I do the global chess Festival
annually
and some of my friends were telling me
that well in this Festival I can see
your style your chest time which means
that I'm very creative also when I'm
organizing something
uh I picked the moment I'm flexible and
the resilient on reconsidering things
I like original things but I like to
make my preparation as well
so you always have to come up with New
Alternatives whenever the festival is
over the next day immediately we always
consider what were the good and the
things which we want to improve so it's
a it's all the time being self-critical
that's also something very important
chess can offer to kids also that
everything what I learned through chess
and through
the competitive person I was I was
implementing it whether it's interior
design I'm organizing an event or a
program or whatever I design
I see the reflection of my chest style
you mentioned cooking as well when we
chatted well for cooking when you don't
have a recipe but you have to do
something then you have to be creative
absolutely well Judith thank you so much
thank you for being such an inspiration
thank you for showing us what can be
done and once again congratulations on
being inducted into the world Chess Hall
of Fame another round of applause please
for Judith
okay everyone so I think we've all
learned just how crucial chess is from a
Scholastics perspective as well as an
arts and culture perspective I'd like
you to turn your attention to a short
video right now showcasing the vital
impact of Chess here in the St Louis
Community
I get to like basically find all of
these really cool connections between
the Chess World and not just the music
world but the creative space
[Music]
yeah so it's part of the music series I
was asked to work with the curator
Shannon
on the Fishers basket exhibit just shows
how if nothing else music can become the
soundtrack of the movement to of uh
what's going to be happening at you at
the Chess Hall of Fame at the chess club
too many times
and I think that what I'm most excited
about is to see how these two worlds of
Chess and music
like fully correlate and integrate
together to create an amazing experience
for our community
to me that's more than a more than a
good enough reason to support uh the
work that we do here at the chess club
and within the World Chess Hall of Fame
[Music]
chess and music have uh some very
interesting combinations and very
interesting overlaps as a concert
pianist myself besides the fact that
there's so much black and white involved
in what both of us do there's this sense
of creativity within a structure the
exhibits are so vivid and and present
even when we have a concert you can see
around you this presence of of grand
Masters and you know seminal chess
matches that were so important to
history it could not be a more
um a more important part of this
community and something that you want to
support because of the way that it
touches all those parts of culture and
the ways that you can encounter so many
different things and people and
experiences all in one place
it's a science it's mathematic it's an
art
so I think that is one of the reasons
chess should be in schools it covers a
wide range of interest for children or
in at least in with my students they
become very real like people in the
science of life and the way that they
move their weaknesses and their
strengths and they become those pieces
and they practice those moves on in the
game and in their lives sometimes if
they can really get that takeaway which
is a goal for me
foreign
chess is a great experience and like I
mentioned before it opens doors for
students to experience things they
haven't before different from where they
come from and and it offers so much to
their social emotional development
especially if we get them very young so
I think chess doing that in schools adds
a great support to students and parents
so they need it
foreign
[Music]
how was that everybody
[Music]
good evening
my name is Renita for those of you who
have never met me and I don't know who
you are
I'm on every morning from like 4 30 to 7
unless you are a late Riser I just want
to thank you all first of all for being
here tonight
this is a tremendous night that's going
to have a huge impact not just on the
chess community
but also on the St Louis Community on
the youth as well as those who are just
looking to better themselves because the
game itself goes beyond just moves on a
board it really is strategies for life
and what the kids are learning by
learning this game is that they can
achieve something by using their brains
not So Much by being the best at
dribbling or shooting or throwing or
catching but being the best at thinking
and overcoming
and not only that but also understanding
the respect that they have for the
opposition to know that the opposition
also had to make moves and counter moves
and there's something joyful in all of
that there's something about watching
that video and seeing
the smiles on the kids faces to know
that this game has indeed changed their
lives
realized that 85
000 kids in the St Louis area have
benefited from the World Chess Hall of
Fame and from the chess club itself do
you understand that 85
000 lives have changed because of that
it is incredible
but tonight we want to make sure that 85
000 plus more lives are changed because
of the game of chess
we want to make sure that what we are
establishing tonight goes well beyond
2022.
well beyond our years
but changes the world forever
you guys with me on that tonight
are you serious
are you with me on that tonight
so far tonight we've had the quiet we've
had the interviews we've had the you
know dinner and all that stuff now it's
time to get crazy now it's time to get
wild now it's time to let your other
side come out because tonight it is
about the celebration of the game of
chess and what the game of chess has
done
for St Louis and for our world
for our communities
so I want you tonight to be a part of
this
I would like to encourage each and every
one of you tonight to support this
incredible cause
we do have tax credits available
tonight so that if you are at LLC or
have a rental income you may qualify
that information is on the screens
behind me
keep that in mind when you are
considering your donations tonight and
the contributions you will make
paddles with numbers or on your tables
they are labeled with your name as well
so please make sure that the paddle you
raise is the correct battle that has
your name on it
okay the guy over here has got 8 000
battles everybody at this table is going
to make a contribution tonight so let me
see those paddles real quick I'm not
going to tally anything just yet so put
the paddles in the air let's make sure
we have them we can see them thank you
very much is your name on that paddle
okay yeah I like there's only like two
yeses everybody's like oh no
oh no oh no all right I appreciate you I
appreciate you you guys doing well
that's my table over here sorry I
couldn't make it for dinner
but Mr Knight had to chill
Mr Knott had the chill today we've got a
number of numbers to give you
and when there is a number that fits you
well there is a number you feel that I
can make that contribution I want you to
raise your number in the air and I'm
going to call out that number
normally on nights like tonight I would
say hey whatever is comfortable for you
but because of what we've gone through
over the last couple of years I know
that life has been uncomfortable for a
lot of people
so I want you to really consider
stretching yourselves tonight to make a
difference
to make a difference for those who
really need your help
our first number tonight is thirty
thousand dollars anyone tonight able to
do a donation of thirty thousand dollars
I've got number one hundred right up
front at thirty thousand dollars
anyone else tonight at thirty thousand
anyone else at thirty thousand anyone
I've got over here number 128 at thirty
thousand dollars thank you very much
anyone else at 30. anyone else at thirty
thousand dollars
oh well let's hear it come on
come on thirty thousand we just made
sixty thousand dollars in a matter of
like two minutes
our next number is twenty thousand
dollars looking for a twenty thousand
dollar donation anyone tonight able to
do twenty thousand dollars looking for
twenty thousand anyone at twenty
thousand dollars tonight
anyone in the room at 20. anyone at 20
no problem that's okay
let's move on to our next number ten
thousand dollars anyone tonight able to
go ten thousand dollars for the donation
to make a difference to have an impact
on all the kids that I see I need to go
way back here way back here because 104
is way up front I would miss you by
standing up here 104
145. it's a 145 for what 145. anyone
else tonight at ten thousand dollars
anyone else at ten thousand looking for
ten thousand anyone else at ten thousand
dollars
well let's hear it for ten thousand and
our thirty thousand dollar donations
tonight
our next number is five thousand dollars
anyone oh wow this guy here quick draw
mcdraw I said
and he was ready to go I got number 364
at five thousand dollars anyone else at
five thousand dollars today looking for
number 138 at five thousand dollars
anyone else at five thousand looking for
five thousand dollars anyone else at
five thousand dollars number one eighty
five at five thousand dollars tonight
anyone else at 5 000 looking for the
five thousand dollar donation at this
time
well let's hear for five thousand ten
thousand and thirty thousand dollars so
far
twenty five hundred dollars is our next
number twenty five hundred dollars
anyone tonight even well okay here we go
number 142 at twenty five hundred number
158 at twenty five hundred dollars
anyone else at twenty five hundred
looking for the twenty five hundred
dollar donations anyone else at twenty
five hundred anyone else at twenty five
twenty five
all right let's hear for our donation so
far
who's trying to follow me with the
camera
is it you
tough job isn't it
normally I sit in one place but now I've
got free reign of the catwalk baby I'm
gonna do that thing
and look at that
big ass head isn't it
anyone
you got to have fun when you can you
know what I mean and right now I've got
the mic and the camera hey anyone
tonight at one thousand dollars looking
for the one a thousand dollar donation
anyone at one thousand number three
Forty Nine at one thousand dollars
number 346 at one thousand number 174 at
one thousand number 149 at one thousand
dollars number 127 at one thousand
dollars anyone else at one thousand
number 173 at one thousand dollars
anyone else at one thousand looking for
the one thousand dollar bid anyone else
anyone um number 321 with a one thousand
dollar donation thank you very much
thank you anyone else anyone else at one
thousand anyone else at one thousand
dollars how are we doing so far
come on Amy
give it up it's like a Blues game in
here all right our next number is 500.81
at 500 tonight looking for the whoa all
right here we go all right
all right testing my eyesight out number
328 at 500 number 218 at 500 number 203
at 500. number 213 at 500 216 at 500
168.
144
134
120.
anyone else at 500 tonight anyone else
at 500.
155 at 500 and by the way you're looking
very Dapper very Dapper tinnitus this
would have acknowledge that fact anyone
else at 500 a night anyone else
why is everybody behind me
all right number 150
let me step back here 150 at 500 and I
thank you sir thank you anyone else
anyone else at 500 okay let's hear it
come on
what you really need to understand and
grasp
is that yeah we're making donations yeah
we're helping fund things but what
you're doing are changing lives
understand what you're doing tonight is
changing lives as we know that our
society isn't one that is easy
every morning I talk about things on the
air that I need to depress when I get
off the air because my goodness it is so
depressing at times
but people like you in this room tonight
are committing to make a difference
you may not know it you may not feel it
but down the line the folks are going to
benefit from this are going to be that
much better because of you
you are that player to stepping up in
the bottom of the ninth any two outs on
the board down by three and you hit that
grand slam home run people are cheering
and going crazy there are kids out there
that are going to go my goodness I'm
able to play this game this game is
changing my life I'm learning so many
things that down the line are going to
be factors and making me successful it
is because of a night like tonight
it is because of people like you that
that is possible
so please don't take what we're doing
lightly we're having fun and we're
conversing and we're talking about a
game but we're really talking about The
Game of Life
we truly are
I've got two more numbers
my next number is 250 dollars anyone
tonight able to go 250. let's do this
number 329 at three at 250. number 331
254
288
285 to 80 280 Mr enthusiastic 281 338.
373.
384 lady with a big smile on her face
very happy to be here number 146.
number 248.
anyone else tonight at 250 anyone else
at 250
or I have one more number one more
number let's see how many how many
paddles we can get up with this last
number our last number is one hundred
dollars one hundred dollars who tonight
could go one hundred dollars all right
here we go 152 at 100
172. let's hear it 172 at 100.
300 at 100.
269.
241.
275.
232
287 248.
371.
186
anyone else did I miss a number
348
341 387.
anyone else anyone else
okay I have to look because I have to
spin because you know I'm way up there
and there's people back here and I don't
know what's happening
I got I got 341 I believe I got 341 I
believe
everybody else
please Round of Applause
no seriously I don't know how much money
we just tallied up but I believe we
tallied up a lot
I've got one more thing to do but I left
the car down here so I gotta go down
here and pick it up and those of you who
who don't realize it Randy not said old
man
it's kind of hard for me to move got a
bad back got a bad hip I have trigger
fingers I can't move my two fingers on
my left hand but that's not an issue
it's not an issue people dealing with
bigger things
these are small things that we're going
to get through and move on and do well
with but we got to take care of our
overall community
so tonight we did the fundraiser did the
funding need that was great we did big
numbers
but what I want you to do besides take
home a full Heart by doing that is I
want you to have the opportunity to take
something home that you go you know what
look darling we're going to get away for
a little while
or wow I got an experience to take part
in because now we're going to proceed to
the live auction and to do the live
auction I have to change glasses
they got to put on the readers
like I said Mr Knott is not as young as
he used to be
our first auction item
is on the IX experience watch the St
Louis Blues take on the Toronto Maple
Leafs up close and personal on Tuesday
December 27th
this experience includes two tickets
front row on the glass on the attack
side of the rink
experience also includes Pub 67 and rink
sign Club access featuring crave worthy
snacks appetizers paired with Spirits
beer wine oh oh by the way parking is
also included that's huge am am I right
am I right
you get on TV a lot
more than I get on TV
what
I need these seats I need these seats I
want to thank you so much for making
this contribution let's begin the
bidding on this on the Ike's experience
at 400 looking for that 400 elevated by
a four you gotta go 400 over four dollar
got four now they've got affordable F5
500 back let's go six anybody has 600 I
don't have five in the back I've got 500
also back looking for 600. I have six
now anybody at seven looking for a seven
little bit I got 600. I have 600
everybody has seven looking for seven
but it's everybody seven I've got a 600
of anybody is seven looking for that 700
on a minute I've got seven now anybody
at eight looking for 800 F7 I have seven
over here let's go eight let's go eight
I've got seven I got this eight let's go
eight let's go eight I got seven hundred
I have seven I'm still looking at you
even though I'm looking that way I've
got peripheral vision 800 now 800 do not
let him get those seats you know you
love hockey he's right across from you
he contributed these tickets make sure
you get to thank your friend my God
thank you for this opportunity to go to
the hockey game right now this guy's
gonna go
I mean hey he looks like a nice guy you
know I love him because you know he's
making a contribution what are we at
like nine thousand dollars on this right
now
9.1 million 800 800 800 800 ago 900. can
I go nine look over 900.9 everybody had
nine look at 900.8 everybody getting
900. looking for 900 about have eight
800 going once
800 going twice
nine hundred dollars now nine hundred
dollars then Mr Mr Vegas on the back
table he's at the back table Mr Vegas
I've got a full house he's got 900 over
1 000. can I go one thousand one
thousand one thousand got a one thousand
nine hundred looking for one thousand
let me get a 900 900 go to once nine
hundred dollars going twice you gotta go
one thousand one thousand got nine
hundred dollars sold nine hundred
dollars enjoy
was there somebody behind me
they were close
you know what they need to shout shouts
shouts let it all out where's my 9 900
bidder was 100 number nine I got a nine
okay we got it now
oh we got more to go
you you keep your hand ready to go our
next one is the Mizzou chess club
experience
oh yeah oh yeah
this experience unlike any other
features one of the hottest teams in
Collegiate chess this package for 10 is
an evening with the Mizzou chess club
and more and more now get this as a
remembrance
of the experience you also receive a
local handcrafted Artisan Mizzou
chessboard marking you as a friend of
the team we can't wait for you to come
to Mizzou for this once in a lifetime
chance it's a date for the event to be
determined on a mutual agreeable date
so this is your chance to hang out with
the Mizzou team this is your chance to
have a very special chessboard made in
your honor we want to begin the bidding
at 700 anyone at 700 looking for that
700 bid anybody has seven 700 for the
Mizzou chess experience 700 gonna get a
700 bid looking for seven now seven
hundred dollars anyone at seven hundred
can we go 700 anybody at seven let's
bring it down a little bit anybody at
five kind of go 500 now looking for the
500 on the bid on the Mizzou chess
experience anyone at 500 I have 500 Novi
thank you thank you I have to keep
stepping back because I keep missing all
the people up front anyone else I've got
a 500 bid got to go 600 looking for 600
bid I got five I have the 500 bid
anybody at six looking for the 600 a
little bit we got five we got five
anybody at six five six six I got five
hundred dollars going once
500 is going twice
sold five hundred dollars enjoy the
Mizzou experience 107 number 107.
Baseball fans you're gonna love this
tossed the first pitch in 2023
through the honorary first pitch at the
2023 St Louis Cardinals game this
package also includes four Field Box
tickets
four Field Box tickets plus before the
game you get to step out and throw out
the first pitch
we'll begin the biddy tonight at one
thousand dollars looking for the one
thousand dollar bid now anyone at one
thousand dollar for the St Louis
Cardinals experience opportunity to
throw out the first pitch as well as
four box seats one thousand dollars is
our bid anyone at one thousand looking
for that one thousand little Betty but
at one thousand can I go one thousand
dollars anybody at one thousand I now
have number one you've got to yell
hey I'm over here one number 120 right
now one thousand one thousand by Eleven
Hundred kind of 1100 I got one thousand
I have one thousand dollars over here
anybody Eleven Hundred over Eleven
Hundred I got one thousand one thousand
dollars of Eleven Hundred now eleven I
gotta go 12 12 now 12 gonna go 13. look
over 1300 but I got twelve I got twelve
for everybody I got 1300. looking for a
thirteen hundred dollar bid I've got a
twelve hundred dollar bid anybody at
thirteen looking for the 1300 I have
twelve got a twelve twelve going what's
twelve hundred to thirteen now thirteen
hundred dollars got to go 14. look over
fourteen hundred dollars we have
thirteen I've got thirteen hundred
dollars but I have fourteen thirteen
hundred dollars good what's
the 1300 is going twice
fourteen hundred dollars see I I that's
that pause I do that pause for that one
reason give him time to think I've got
fourteen hundred dollars in that fifty
over fifty nickel fifteen now fifteen
hundred dollars gonna go sixteen looking
for the 1600 bid I got 15. I have
fifteen hundred dollars anybody at
sixteen sixteen hundred dollars that is
everything we got sixteen sixteen gonna
go 17 over 17 they got sixteen hundred
dollars sixteen hundred dollars going
once
sixteen hundred dollars go
1700 1700 go to what's
Seventeen hundred dollars going twice
sold Seventeen hundred dollars in Joy
the St Louis Cardinals package
number again
[Applause]
was was 241
oh 249 249 240.
how you doing
our next number
oh honorary Observer experience
enjoy the experience to walk inside the
ropes
with the PGA Tour Champions as this
honorary Observer experience at the
Ascension Charity Classic on Saturday
September the 9th 2023 at Norwood Hills
Country Club the package includes VIP
parking pass
Club 314 seats and admission to the
tournament grounds as an honorary
Observer on Saturday September the 9th
so this is your chance to step inside
the ropes to walk alongside the golfers
and be right there to listen to them
strategize and everything else they talk
about as they play the game of golf
let's begin the bidding at 500 anyone at
500. looking for that 500 bid anybody at
500 over 500 now 500 anybody a 500 or
500 500 500 in the back now anybody at
six I have a 500 bid anybody has 600 for
six only got 500. I have 500 anybody has
600. anyone has 600 we have five I have
500 looking for six 500 going once
500 going twice
sold 500 enjoy your time inside the
ropes number 301 number 301
no really more Applause than that
thank you
Maryland house happy hour coming soon to
44 Maryland Plaza in the Central West
End is Maryland house by Brennan's
for two hours 20 guests will enjoy an
all-inclusive happy hour at Maryland
house this is the best seat in the house
along with high-end hors d'oeuvres and
Cocktails now this will be a mutually
agreeable date but a chance to bring 20
people to the Maryland house and have it
all out hors d'oeuvres drinks and really
it's a great time to have an office
party to impress not just your office
mates but to let them know how much you
appreciate who they are
let's begin the bidding on this at 500
to leave for that 500 bid I have 500 in
the back now anybody has 600. looking
for a 600 a little bit F5 I have the 500
bid in the back anybody in six six now
gotta go 7-7 over here kind of 800
looking for 800 at seven
what is that a thousand I have a
thousand dollars I have a thousand
dollars right here anybody at Eleven
Hundred I have a one thousand dollar
Billy but eleven over eleven got one
thousand one thousand dollars eight by
the eleven
thank you thank you for shouting money
man eleven hundred dollars off here
anybody until look at 12 look at 12
again eleven I have Eleven Hundred a
little bit looking for it
why do you have me counting one five
fifteen hundred dollars
fifteen hundred dollars on the man who
says you know I'm gonna make my own way
I'm not waiting for you to get that high
I'm going to do it myself fifty hundred
dollars if it has 16 1600 I got 15. 50
100 of everybody at sixteen hundred
looking for sixteen hundred dollars at
fifteen of sixteen hundred dollars of
everybody at Seventeen hundred Seventeen
sir two thousand dollars now
this guy is a shot caller baller he just
calls his own numbers I love it two
thousand dollars over here anybody at
twenty one he had to go twenty one
hundred dollars I got two thousand I
have two thousand dollars anybody at
Twenty One Eleven Twenty One anybody of
twenty one I have two thousand man I'd
like a big butt
I don't like that camera angle who's got
that camera that camera off me right now
I have two thousand dollars anybody at
2100 over 21 to 21 I got two thousand
two thousand dollars going what's
21 now 21 now 20. are you even old
enough to get in the Maryland house
get it can you show me your credentials
and uh not that I don't trust you
everybody look awfully young you're
aging well by the way twenty one hundred
dollars everybody got twenty two can I
get a 22. twenty five hundred twenty
five twenty five hundred yeah yeah
anybody at 20. whoa they cut you off
it really you this is your time to exert
your Authority
this is your time oh no no no no okay I
maybe next time maybe next time twenty
five hundred dollars over here anybody
at 26 looking for twenty six hundred
dollars I got 25 2 500 going what's
twenty five hundred dollars going twice
twenty five hundred dollars sold enjoy
the Maryland house number three six four
three six four
[Applause]
and hopefully I I say this right because
I'm not
educated on this particular package
Adora Adora
Adora VIP luxury shopping
Audra Audra thank you Audra okay this
Factor includes a one-hour private
styling and shopping session for you and
two friends with Audra noise
they help me
noise Herndon a Paris train fashion
designer and founder create a designer
for St Louis based luxury women's wear
Audra odra Audra help me help me ahadra
all right so this is your opportunity
for you to be a part of something really
special because I understand that Susan
Sarandon and Kim Kardashian
do this
you're going to get a 100 gift card for
each of your guests total of three
the package expires on June 30th 2023.
so this is a chance to meet the designer
she will help you go through the steps
and get you prepared for the experience
of a lifetime let's begin the bidding at
three hundred dollars three hundred
dollars anyone at 300 looking for a 300
bid for this exclusive fashion
thank you very much exclusive fashion
experience at three hundred dollars have
300 on anybody a four can I go 400 is
going to go for anybody a Four f three
hundred I now have 400 over here four
anybody at five can I go five and
arrowser 500 I got 500 I gotta go four
five hundred now to get 500 nominee at
600. can anybody has six hundred dollars
I got five over here anybody at six 600
down 600 million seven kind of goes 700
I have six I have six anybody at 700.
anyone at 700 it's way cheaper than the
Maryland house I have 600 somebody has
seven anyone has 700 they have six six
hundred thirty that's seven now seven
hundred dollars a minute eight gotta go
eight what
700 back there yeah that guy oh there's
another one eight somebody who's over
there at 800 800 800 807 still at seven
or eight hundred
okay I have seven anybody eight hundred
dollars I have 800 over the guy but here
now this guy you missed him you got him
you missed him 800 over everybody had
nine gotta go nine I got 800 800 is
going to what's
800 going twice
800 sold in joy
number please
[Applause]
244 244. all right I have two more two
more items two more items experience the
green seats the green seats you and four
friends will enjoy the St Louis
Cardinals game like a VIP while enjoying
the perks and Hospitality of the most
premium area of Busch Stadium
the Cardinals Club as well the Cardinals
Club aka the green seats is located
directly behind home plate
if you've never been there it is the
experience of a lifetime not only do you
get the seats you have in-seat service
they bring you food they bring you
beverage and you will get two VIP
parking passes
this incredible package includes five
tickets to the Cardinals game on Friday
May 19th 2023.
five tickets to the game VIP parking
green seats
food beverage included a chance to take
in the Cardinals club and and be seen on
TV talking on your cell phone as you
wave to family and friends telling them
yes I have arrived I am in the green
seats we'll begin this at 500 looking
for the 500 bid now they got 500 in the
back anybody at 600 can it goes six
seven to go seven seven now seven over
here go to 800. looking for 800 to 800
now on anybody at nine noted can I get a
900 vehicle for nine I've got 809 now
900 everybody one thousand one thousand
to back Eleven Hundred looking for
eleven hundred dollars I got nine I
already got one thousand I have one
thousand looking for eleven hundred
dollar bid anyone at eleven hundred
dollars I've got one thousand dollars
one thousand dollars in about eleven
hundred one thousand dollars going once
I have 11 now 11 I'm here gonna go 12 or
12. now I got 1100 up front now 1100 but
I got 12. 1100 Watts 1100 is going twice
eleven hundred dollars
sold enjoy the St Louis Cardinals and
the green seats with four of your
friends five tickets your number sir
the number 167 167.
one more item
one more item and then my voice will go
silent until Monday morning at 4 30.
a custom Fisher spasky shoes
show off your love of the 1972 match of
the century with these custom designed
Nike Blazer shoes
look at that
oh Checkmate and everything on there an
opportunity for you to strut your stuff
everywhere across town with the most
fashionable shoes on the planet let's
begin the bidding at three hundred
dollars anybody out there use sneaker
heads at 300 I have 300 now anybody at
350. I have 300 but he had 350 over 350
and I have 300 350 can I go 400 400 400
floating a four now five five and over
here now six gotta go seven seven over
here anybody eight hundred dollars 800
of everybody at nine gotta go 900 or
800. I have nine nine where's nine
where's nine nine now in the back down
any better one thousand gotta go one
thousand one thousand everybody Eleven
Hundred eleven look at 1100 we have One
Thousand Eleven now anybody at 12 are
they even your size
are they even your size
okay you gotta you gotta keep that you
you may have to stuff it with newspaper
but you're gonna wear those things young
man you know trust me if you if you get
those shoes every single day you're
gonna they'll they will come and they
will put them on your feet for you I
have 1100 oh 12. never mind I have 1200
I've been at 13 for 13 now 14 1400 1500
everybody has 1600. you gotta go 1600 I
got 16 on anybody at 17. you got to go
mom is now holding down the paddle
do not raise that battle I've got
sixteen hundred dollars anybody has
Seventeen hundred looking for a 1700 I
got a 16. yes you might want to go ahead
and grab it I have 600 winner 7600 let's
go once
sixteen hundred dollars going twice
sixteen hundred dollars oh
whoa hold on just so I make sure I don't
get on detention
is it okay
okay it's it's coming out of his money
right okay 1700 you got a lot you got a
lot of chores oh you know you go to my
house and rake leaves too I'll pay you
1700 right here anybody 18. never mind
never mind he's he could really rake
1800 anybody in 1900 1800 good once
1800 going twice
sold eighteen hundred dollars in joy
a very special pair of Nikes uh your
number
number 159 159.
okay now at your tables
at your tables you will notice this
extravagant display of flowers and a vas
and everything else
if you donate fifty dollars
and you're the one from your table that
does that you can take home the display
so it's going to be fifty dollars I've
got number 135 is going 50 for hers
anyone else anyone on the table here any
one of the tables
you don't need it I got number 348 for
the table to the back I've got number
275 for the other table in the back
I've got number I don't know what that
is 138 right here number 150 right there
anyone else wanted to take home the
arrangement on the table
anyone else anyone else
all right you don't need to make the
decision right now but when you do
please let this young lady right here
with the notepad and the black blazer
and the lovely lace dress know that you
want to take home the arrangement and
she will make that happen for you at
this time I want to say thank you so
much for letting me be a part of your
night
thank you so much for your contributions
but now we return you to the more
civilized portion of the evening please
welcome back Debbie and Amy
I'm in ready not
thank you Rennie
on behalf of the St Louis chess club in
the World Chess Hall of Fame thank you
so much for making tonight such a
success your generosity truly makes a
difference in the lives of children
today and in the future thank you all so
much for joining us we'll see you next
year have a great rest of your night
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited